my words and bear witness to my vow now
gathers and now my watch begins
that shall not end until my death I
should take no wife hold no lands father
no children I shall wear no crowns and
win no glory I shall live and die at my
post I am the sword in the darkness I am
The Watcher on the walls our and the
shield that guards have no realm of men
I pledge my life and honor to the Nights
Watch for this night and all the nights
to come your breath winter is coming and
the winter is coming winter is coming
and winter is coming but winter is
coming winter is coming winter is coming
winter is coming
Oh before winters done
everyone you've ever known will be dead
the Lannisters and the regard you want
justice you've come to the roof
Lannister Targaryen Baratheon stark
Tyrell they will just spokes on a wheel
this one's on top and that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground it's a beautiful dream
stopping the wheel you're not the first
person who's ever dreamt it
I'm not going to stop the wheel I'm
going to break the wheel the realm do
you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
but what do we have left once we abandon
the lie chaos a gaping pit waiting to
swallow us all chaos isn't a pit chaos
is our ladder you want to be handed the
king you want to rule this is what
ruling is lying on a bed of weeds
ripping them out by the root one by one
before they strangle you in your sleep
look at you you know what you want me to
do you know it has to be done monsters
are dangerous and just now Kings are
dying like flies do you think this has a
happy ending you haven't been paying
attention when you play the game of
Thrones you win you die I made a mistake
a horrible mistake I underestimated a
stranger tell me about the Targaryen
girl in the east and her dragons
curiosities on the far side of the world
are no threat to us and how do we know
these dragons are just curiosities and
not the beasts that brought the whole
world to heel you want revenge against
the Lannisters I killed my father Tywin
Lannister with a boat to the heart I am
the greatest Lannister killer of our
time I am Daenerys Stormborn of House
Targaryen of the blood of old Valyria I
am the Dragons daughter and I swear to
you that those who would harm you will
die screaming the North remembers we
know no king but a king in the North his
name is stark I don't care if with a
busted leg starts blood runs through his
veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day I'm not a stark you know
nothing
run amok Lucas and I will go left only a
fool would trust Littlefinger told the
truth
you always know when a man is telling a
lie how did you acquire this magical
power I grew up in King's Landing
power resides where men believe it
resides it's a trick a shadow on the
wall and a very small man can cast a
very large shadow my name is Jon Snow
your grace
and that's darksome your father was no
naraba man he was your grace and win to
his coin
obviously here son spent at me look at
me
Stannis is a killer
the Lannisters are killers your father
was a killer your brother is a killer
your sons will be killers someday no
elders built by killers so you're better
get used to looking at them he won't
hurt me oh my sweet summer child what do
you know about fear fear is for the
winter when the snows fall a hundred
feet deep fear is for the long night
when the Sun hides for years and
children are born and live and die all
in darkness that is the times of fear my
little Lord when the White Walkers moved
through the woods
thousands of years ago there came a
night that lasted a generation Kings
froze to death in their castles same as
the Shepherd's in the hoods and women
smothered their babies rather than see
them starve and wept and felt the tears
freeze on their cheeks so is this the
sort of story that you like
in that darkness the White Walkers came
to the first kind they swept through
cities and kingdoms riding the board
horses Raven came to insist to go
a white Raven
[Music]
in truth here
[Music]
father always promised in me